ام
يواصل وزير الخارجيه الامريكي جون كيري
مباحثات بين الجانبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي في اطار جولته الحاليه
الراميه للتوصل الى اتفاق اطار بين
الجانبين نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في
محورين
الجديد الذي ياتي به كل هذه المره لحلحله
المفاوضات في ظل تمسك كل طرف بمواقفه
وما هي فرص نجاح وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
في الخروج بنتائج ايجابيه هذه المره
وسط حاله من الشك وعدم الثقه بين الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
تاتي مباحثات وزير الخارجيه الامريكي جون
كيري بهدف ابرام اتفاق اطار يمهد للحل
النهائي غير ان مهمه كيري لن تكون سهله
بسبب حجم الخلافات بشان القضايا الجوهريه
في الصراع وهذا يعني ان المرحله الحاليه
من المفاوضات التي بدات في يوليو تموز
الماضي بسقف زمني ينتهي في ابريل نيسان
المقبل قد لا تعطي للاداره الامريكيه
النجاح الذي كانت تامله
جون كيري في فلسطين للمره العاشره في اقل
من عام في جوع دام للثقه بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين يسعى وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الى التوصل لاتفاق اطار مثير
للجدل حتى قبل ان يرى النور قبل رام الله
ولقاء الرئيس ابو مازن كان كيري قد بدا
زيارته ب محادثات مع المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين تعهد لرئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو بالعمل مع الجانبين الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني بشكل مكثف من اجل تضييق هوه
الخلافات بشان اتفاق الاطار المامول من
قبل واشنطن مهمته قد تكون اعقد من المرات
السابقه بالنظر الى ما سبق هذه الزياره
تازمت قضيه غور الاردن بعد موافقه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على مشروع قانون بضمه ونشر
قوات دائمه فيه واستثنائه من اي مفاوضات
في المستقبل امر ترفضه الدوله الفلسطينيه
التي تقترح وجود قوات دوليه في غور الاردن
وانسحاب اسرائيل منها نهائيا مساله
الاستيطان عقبه اخرى امام
انفراج نسبي واي جهود دوليه لانجاح مسار
السلام بين الجانبين مشاريع الاستيطان
مستمره في عام الفين واربعه عشر بالرغم من
انتقادات واشنطن والدول الغربيه
اما العقبات المعهوده في ملف المفاوضات
فهي وضع القدس الامن والحدود وحق العوده
بالنسبه للفلسطينيين اكد ابو مازن قبل
وصولك يرى انه لن يتردد في القول لا ومهما
كانت الضغوط لاي مقترح ينتقد او يلتف على
المصالح العليا للشعب الفلسطيني
الفلسطينيون لن يقبلوا ايضا بدقيقه واحده
لتمديد فتره التفاوض المحدده بتسعه اشهر
ولن يكون مفاجئا اذا قررت يرى تمديد
بزيارته للمنطقه كما حدث سابقا لانتزاع
موافقه على اتفاق اطار بدل اتفاق نهائي
صعب المنال لانهاء الصراع في الشرق الاوسط
ما هي الضغوط الجديده وهل تاتي اكلها هذه
المره واذا اقنع كيري الطرفين باتفاق اطار
مهما كان الثمن ترى ما هو الثمن الذي
سيدفعه الفلسطينيون مقابل القبول به
معنا في هذه الحلقه من رام الله الدكتور
مشعل اللقطات استاذ الاعلام في جامعه
بيرزيت من تل ابيب ورام 2
رئيس قسم دراسات الشرق الاوسط في جامعه بن
غوريون
واه من واشنطن جورج فورمان مدير برنامج
الشرق الاوسط في مركز الدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والدوليه اه من تل ابيب
ضيفنا اسمه يوري مثل عفوا اه نبدا من اه
اه واشنطن سيد ان هل ترى هذه المره جاء في
وثيقه تتعلق بجوهر النزاع ووضع حد له
ماذا الوزير ترى هو في الواقع ما كان قد
نناقشه مع الاطراف المعنيه منذ توليه هذا
المنصب قبل سنه تقريبا لديه ايضا كل
الوثائق
والسجلات الى جانب التجربه تجربه مورتن هو
ال السفير السابق المفوض السابق اه لدى
اذن هذا الارهاب التاريخ الذي يحمله ولديه
على ما اعتقد كذلك
مقربه او ما قد يكون مفيدا في الواقع يسهل
ان يغرق في كواليس دبلوماسيه لكن اعتقد ان
جوهر القضيه الان هو مشكله سياسيه بمعنى
ان لدينا سياسيين يترددون اتخذت الخطوات
الدبلوماسيه الضروريه التي ترى الولايات
المتحده وغيرها لهم ان ياخذوها ما يحمله
جون كيري لا يقتصر على التاريخ بل ايضا
وجهه النظر السياسيه لدفع السياسيين
الاخرين يتصرفوا ب حسب وجهه نظره ايضا
ولكن هل وجهه النظر هذه السيد مشهد الوقت
هل وجهه النظر هذه تعكس اه اه الموقف
الامريكي اكثر منها حل يريد فرضه على
الجانبين
هي اكثر من ذلك هي تعكس المطالب
الاسرائيليه غير المنتهيه بمساله الامن هو
يريد الحدود ويريد ال غور الاردن ويريد
القدس
ويتنازل عن حق العوده هذه ليست مواقف
سياسيه هذه مبادئ اساسيه في المفاوضات
عندما قبل الطرف الفلسطيني هذه المفاوضات
قبلها على اساس ان تكون حدود السبعه وستين
حدود السبعه وستين لا تحتاج الى تفسير ولا
تحتاج الى فلسفه والى ولا الى سياسه هناك
ارض احتلت عام سبعه وستين تعتبر ارض محتله
عند كل الامم المتحده وعند كل الشرائع
السماويه والارضيه الان الامريكان يحاولون
تسويق موقف جديد ان هناك مواقف سياسيه
هناك
ومطالب للاطراف هناك وقائع على الارض
وبالتالي هذه المفاوضات لا يوجد مفاوضات
كل ما يتم في هذه اللحظه هو ان اسرائيل
تحاول فرض سياسه الامر الواقع استخدام
القوه ال الانحياز الكامل لصالح اسرائيل
حاله الضعف او التاهل في الفلسطين
والانقسام حاله الضعف العربي والانشغال في
الحروب الداخليه ل تفرضه حلا يحمي اسرائيل
من المستقبل كل هذه الشروط تعكس نفسيه
اسرائيل
اليهود الذين يشعرون بالخوف من المستقبل
لانهم يعلمون ان هذه الارض من بحرها الى
نهرها قد سرقت من اهلها ولكن ولكن سيد سيد
من يتابع ال ال التعليق والمحللين
الاسرائيليون هنا اسال السيد يرام مثال
يحصل لديه انطباع بان
جاء بشيء اه مخيف وعلى نتنياهو ان يحسم
امره ويتخذ قرارات صعبه كيف ينظر في
اسرائيل لم جاء به كل هذه المره
اه اكيد اليمين الاسرائيلي
اه فيه خوف اه في اليمين الاسرائيلي من اه
احتمال
لرئيس الوزراء ان طريق اه يعمل كما عمل
رئيس الوزراء السابق ارييل شارون اه في
يوم الانسحاب من قطاع غزه ولكن اه الكثير
في اسرائيل لا يتوقع اي اتفاق بين اه
الجنديين المخططات بين اه الطرفان اه
اه يعني شيء مهم طبعا ولكن المهم اه اكثر
اه النقطه هي ان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين
نجح في اقناع ال اه الجانب الامريكي
اداره اوباما اه في الشرط الاول بالنسبه
لحكومه اسرائيل
وهذا شرطا اه واه وما زال اه اطراف اه
الجانب الفلسطيني بدوله اسرائيل كدوله
يهوديه هذا مفتاح الموضوع
نتنياهو نجح هنا اه بالنسبه يعني مدهشه في
اه اقناع
الجانب الامريكي
وبعد هذا يعني مواضيع
خالد دائم بين الجانبين يعني مشروط و
مرهون ب اه
اه اقبال او اعتراف بيهوديه الدوله يعني
اذا اذا كان نجح في في ذلك وهنا نسال
السيد انت اذا كانك اه اه نتنياهو نجح في
اقناع كيري بهذا ال الموضوع لماذا لم
يستطع ان ان ان اه ان يقنع نتنياهو
بالمقابل بمجموعه التزامات كان يفترض ان
تتم من الجانب الاسرائيلي واساسا مثلا
موضوع الاستيطان
والان انا لا افهم واما يعني بالدوله
اليهوديه هل هي دوله لليهود هل هي دوله
يحكمها القانون اليهودي من يقرر ما هو
اصلا القانون اليهودي هذه القضيه اذا ما
نظرنا فيها بعمق كل ما زادت صعوبه بالنسبه
لنا واعتقد ان اه هذا كان يهدف الى
التاثير نفسيا
التاثير النفسي وال اسفنا لانه عمليه
تطبيقيا لا اعرف ماذا تعني اليهوديه ولا
اعرف ايضا ماذا تعني اه الدوله اليهوديه
الديمقراطيه لانها عشرين بالمائه من
السكان اسرائيل او ربما ليس من اليهود هذا
لكي نبدا اصلا لكن اعتقد ان القضيه الا
عام هي متصله بمقاربات الوزير كريم التي
تختلف عن السنوات الفائته في اداره اوباما
واعني بذلك
ضروره ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار بحذر
القضايا التي سوف يعترض عليها
الاسرائيليون وايضا ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار
الحساسيات الاسرائيليه ازاء بعض القضايا
اعتقد ان اداره اوباما في البدايه اعتمدت
مقاربه سريه اذا ما جاز التعبير ولم
يتجاوب معها الاسرائيليون بل وجهها فعلا
حتى تم توجهات رئيس وزراء ناتانياهو ما
يحاول الوزير قياده اليوم هو الوصول الى
شراكه بين رئيس الوزراء نتانياهو
وايضا مع الرئيس اوباما واقع الامر هو انه
اذا ما توجهنا نحو حل
بالتفاوض يجب ان يكون قائما على حدود سبعه
وستين مع تبادل الاراضي ان النهي هذا
التبادل ما هي هذه الاراضي هذا امر يتم
التفاوض عليه لكن يفهم الجميع ان هذه
القضيه سوف تكون قائمه على حدود العام
سبعه وستين مع تعديلات على ذلك واعتقد
ايضا
اعتب اعتمده الوزير كاريك السياسي وانه
لابد من هنا بين اه
الرئيس او رئيس الوزراء نتانياهو من جهه
ولكن لا يمكن ان نكتفي
بالدفع هذا لان عنده الدبلوماسيه سوف تفشل
الاتفاق
سيدي الاكثر البعض يشبهه بمسعى كلينتون في
كامب ديفيد في ديسمبر الفين ولكن يقال بان
الفرق انك لم تم طرحه في اخر مدته بين ما
يطرحه وهو لم يمضي بعد اه اه سنه كامله في
وزاره الخارجيه هل تتفق مع هذا التشبيه
صحيح صحيح وهذه الاداره الامريكيه هي جاده
وصادقه و تريد الوصول الى حل الدولتين منذ
اه اه الرئيس الحالي والرئيس كلينتون اه
وخاصه في عهد بوش الاب توصل الامريكان الى
قناعه بضروره حل الدولتين ولكن هذا الحل
لابد ان يكون هناك تنازلات اسرائيل حتى
اللحظه لم تقدم موقف واضح ولا في قضيه من
القضايا الرئيسيه العالقه ولكن بدات هذه
المفاوضات تحت ضغط اسرائيلي على الاداره
الامريكيه
نريد اذا
اضافه بند تبادل اراضي وتم اضافه وهذا بند
خطير بالمناسبه سوف نواجه عواقبه لاحقا
ولكن نلاحظ الان ان هذه القائمه من
المتطلبات الامنيه الاسرائيليه لا تنتهي
ونهايتها اه وليس اخرها احداها الان
يهوديه الدوله اذا كان هذا المطلب بلعب
القرن الواحد والعشرين دوله يهوديه كما
تفضل ضيفك من امريكا معنى لا لا ينطبق في
هذا العصر الديمقراطي هذا يعود الى العصور
الوسطى وكان هذه الشروط وضعتها الاسرائيل
بذكاء وبحنكه لكي يرفضها الجانب الفلسطيني
وطبعا سوف يرفضها فيقال اه ان الطرف
الفلسطيني هو المعطل للوصول الى الاتفاق
هو الذي لا يقبل ولا يريد تسويه وكانها
هذه شروط تعجيزيه وضعت ل ترفض وهنا
المشكله ان الجانب الامريكي بدا يتعاطى مع
الشروط الاسرائيليه ابتداءا من فكره
التبادل الى فكره يهوديه الدوله الى فكره
الاغوار والسيطره عليها ال ابديه لاسرائيل
بنوع من الايجابيه وهذا كانت نتائج اليوم
واضحه ان الشعب الفلسطيني الذي كان يرحب
بك يرى بالامس اليوم استقبله بمظاهرات
وهذه رساله واضحه ولن نتنازل عن صمت ولكن
السيد
معذره ال المشكله انه كيري اذا كان يريد
وهنا اسال قبل الفاصل سيد اه اه مثال كيري
اذا اراد ان يفرض تسويه معينه او اتفاق
اطار عليه ان اه يعكس الاراده الاسرائيليه
في شيء ويعكس الاراده الفلسطينيه في شيء
ما الذي عكسه في الاراده الاسرائيليه سيد
مثال
اه اولا لا احد يعلم هل اه
حمل معه اى برنامج او اى
اطار بين الجانب الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني
ثانيا اه من الخطاب السياسي اه هنا في
اسرائيل
السؤال المهم اه هو اعتراف الجانب
الاسرائيلي اه بيهوديه دوله اسرائيل
ثالثا اه م اه م اه اه في طبعا اه مساله
اه حدود اه حدود الدوله الفلسطينيه
وسياده الدوله الفلسطينيه اللي رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي يستغل وب ب يامل في
المصطلحات ال
الصحيحه يعني نتنياهو بيتكلم اه في اطار
اه حل الدولتين ولكن حل الدولتين كما
يفهمه اه الجانب الاسرائيلي وعلى راسه اه
صنع القرار في اسرائيل هو لا الانسحاب
حدود سبعه وستين
دوله فلسطينيه منقوصه السياده دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله كما اه
شرح اه الضيف من رام الله اه يوافق الجانب
الاسرائيليه على الترتيبات الامنيه اه في
الاردن وفي اماكن اخرى يعني في الضفه
الغربيه او خ او لها اه كتاب غزه يعني
معنا
ان الجانب الاسرائيلي اه اه طالب وممكن
اطلع اللي الجانب الامريكي اه على ترتيبات
امنيه صارمه
يعني اذا اذا كانت اذا كانت مؤسسات الدوله
يعني بعد اذنك اذا كانت مواصفات ال ال
الموقف الامريكي تقريبا هي بهذا الشكل بين
الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي نريد ان
نعرف بعد الفاصل ما هي فرص نجاح اه الوزير
الكوري في الخروج بنتائج ايجابيه في ضوء
اه ما يتم ترويجه الان عن هذا الاتفاق
اللي صار لنا عوده بعد قليل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
ام
ام اهلا بكم من جيد من جديد من زلتم معنا
في هذه الحلقه التي نناقش فيها مباحثات
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه جون كريم مع
الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي سيد اه اه
هل تعتقد بان هذه الجوله وهي العاشره في
اقل من سنه ستكون مفصليه اما ان نصل الى
اتفاق واما ان يعلن فشل
ان الطريقه التي تم تقديم الموضوع فيها لا
تظهر انها سوف تكون زياره اجنده مفصليه
لكن لا تنسوا ان كل هذه الزيارات كانت
محطه بجوار من السريه لم نحصل تسريبات
كثيره لا نعرف الى اين وصلت الامور اعتقد
ان ثمه نقطتين مهمتين هنا ان نذكر او يبدو
ان ثمه شهور دون الراميه الى بناء علاقات
بين الوزير كيري وان الاشخاص الذين يتفاوض
مع هم وهذه الملفات علنيه تارو هذا ابني
جوا من الثقه والنقطه الثانيه يعني الجميع
يعرف ان المفاوضات قائمه بين منه وهو
مفاوضات جديه مع الفلسطينيين و جزئيا مع
الامريكيين وجزئيه ايضا اه ال اسرائيل
السياسيين او ال من السياسيين في اسرائيل
اذن الى جانبه يحصل عالميا لدينا هو
المفاوضات التي لا تجره الداخل قاعه
المفاوضات او مع الاطراف بل ايضا من
الناحيه السياسيه اعتقد انه يجب ان نقارب
الموضوع من وجهه النظر هذه اذا ما سوف نصل
الى نتائج ايجابيه
وذلك بعد وقت طويل بعد شهر ابريل سوف
يتطلب خطوات كثيره او ربما ايضا ت تكشف عن
اه بعد ذلك والسؤال الذي يجب ان يطرح هل
ان هذه المقاربه سوف تكون ناجحه على المدى
الطويل انا فيه بطرح السؤال ما اذا كانت
هذه السياره سوف تنجح هذه السياره هي
واحده من سلسله زيارات طويله يتطلبها
الموضوع ولكن ما ما يعيق لنجاح هذه المره
اه سيد اه اه في في تل ابيب ان اه اه
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيلي والمسؤولين
الاسرائيليين بدؤوا من الان يروجون على ان
الرئيس محمود عباس اه ليس شريكا
وهو يشير بالقتله واه اه كل هذا يمهد وكان
الجانب الاسرائيلي يريد ان يحمل عباس من
الان مسؤوليه اي فشل هل هذا هو التوجه
العام في اسرائيل
اه اعتقد نعم
الاسرائيليين اه ينظروا الى
الجانب الفلسطيني اه اه شريك اه اه
لمخططات ولكن لا للسلام اول حال دائم اه
بين الجانبين اليمين الاسرائيلي اه اه
المتوسط وطبعا المتطرف ضد اي مخططات مع اه
الرئيس محمود عباس ولكن ازور ان لسؤالك اه
ممكن اضيف اه نقطتين الاولى اه الهدف
الرئيسي كما اه اراه اليوم هو استمرار يات
اه
المخططات ولا اه ابرام اتفاق بين الجانبين
في عدد قليل من
المفسرين معلقين هنا في اسرائيل اه
ينظروا الى
المحادثات
امكانيه او فرصه
لابرام اتفاق بين الجانبين الهدف والخروج
بسلام من مختصات السلام بين الجانبين ال
ال النقطه الهامه هنا هي ان اللي الجانب
الاسرائيلي
والجانب الامريكي اه عايزين
شراء وقت بعد من الوقت من المخططات
واستمرار يات المخططات اه
معاك يرى و بين الجانبين اه طبعا اه تشتغل
المصالح الاسرائيليه
اننا اه السيد نتانياهو اه اه اغلبيه
الاسرائيليين فهمين انا شراء الوقت هو
الهدف الرئيسيه اليوم ومنع اه فشل
المفاوضات
وخصوصا اه منع اه
اه اه اه اه اه
حال
للامريكان اه لينظر والاسرائيلي
كمسؤولين على فشل او لا احد يريد ان يتحمل
هذه المسؤوليه ولهذا اسال السيد الاقل اذا
كان الرئيس الراحل ياسر عرفات الحمله
مسؤوليه فشل كامب ديفيد في الفين هل هل
يخشى ان تكون جوله كيري هذه اه سيدفع اه
الجانب الفلسطيني ثمنها ما اذا تمسك ب اه
اه الثوابت كما توصف في الساحه الفلسطينيه
هذا ما نخشاه ان يصل الطرف الامريكي على
طرح هذه المتطلبات الامنيه وخاصه الاغوار
والتنازل عن حق العوده وبالتالي يفسر اه
الموقف الرئيس الفلسطيني على انه رافض
للسلام
ونعود الى نفس المربع الذي وقعنا فيه
بالعام الفين ما عرض على الرئيس عرفات هو
هذا بالضبط التنازل عن حق العوده الثناء
قيل ان القدس اعطى الحرم للفلسطينيين
بالالفين ولكن كان الخلاف الحقيقي حول حق
العوده حق العوده مقدس ويجب ان يعود هؤلاء
الناس خمسه مليون لاجئ الى بيوتهم لا يوجد
لا زعيم فلسطيني ولا اي شخص تحت هذا
السماء يملك حق التنازل عن حق العوده هذه
رساله يجب ان تفهمها اسرائيل هي شردت خمسه
مليون لاجئ و سوف يعودون وهذا منصوص عليه
باتفاقيات دوليه كل ما يجري اليوم هي
الكفاف على كل هذه الاتفاق على هذه
القرارات الدوليه مائه واربعه وتسعين
لايجاد صيغه واتفاق اطار جديد وهو اوسلو
اثنين محسن يعني بدل ما هي سلطه وطنيه
نسميها دوله ناقصه السياده منزوعه السلاح
لا تسيطر على الحدود هذا هو بالضبط
وبالتالي يتم نزع حق العوده لذلك يصر
الجانب الاسرائيلي على شرط جديد يهوديه
الدوله وهذا لا يتنازل عن حق ال خمس مليون
فقط ولكن يضع مليون وسبعمائه الف فلسطيني
في فلسطين ثمانيه واربعين
امام المجهول لذلك اعتقد ان الجانب
الفلسطيني في وضع صعب هو لا يستطيع ان
يقول نعم لهذه الشروط وهو لا يستطيع ان
يقول لا للمفاوضات لان الحصار الذي شهدته
السلطه في العام 2011 كانت قاسيا وصعبا
وخاصه الان في ظل الربيع العربي او ما
يسمى الربيع العربي لم يعد لدى السلطه اي
دعم او حقيقي الا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه شكرا لك دكتور نشرت استاذ
الاعلام في جامعه بيرزيت شكرا ايضا لضيفنا
من واشنطن جون الترمان مدير برنامج الشرق
الاوسط في مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والدوليه شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من تل ابيب
ورام مثال رئيس قسم دراسات الشرق الاوسط
في جامعه بن غوريون
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
هذه النهايه هذه الحلقه التي خصصناها
لجولته نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده في
ما وراء خبر اليوم
ام
نعم